matteo salvini a prononcé un discours à
fort mis sur le balcon ou mussolini
avait assisté dans les années 20 un
massacre de partisans de la démocratie
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé
écoutez matteo salvini se déplace en
italie par tous il va dans les lieux
publics
vous savez si on compte qu'en garde
pouvait sans doute qu'ils emmanuel
macron edouard philippe conduit à passer
outre à des discours ou plat dessert à
des endroits où il ya eu des chefs
d'état français comme très controversé
la très sexy mais évidemment une forte
émotion en et année je vous rappelle
qu'il y avait ces jeunes partisans
effectivement accroché pendus aux
réverbères complexe et les polémiques
dérisoires
c'est pas parce que c'est le symbole
pourquoi parce qu'il fait problème il va
partout en italie il ya du devenir des
discours sur des balcons ou des leaders
communistes dans le passé en q2 discours
si on commence à interdire de tous les
lieux où il ya des personnalités
controversées ou très critiquable ont
mené des actions des discours on pourra
plus aller nulle part
tout ça c'est des polémiques dérisoires
c'est de la petite politique
politicienne ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
dans l'à beaucoup qui sont très agacés
du succès de matteo salvini les bons
résultats qu'il obtient communiste de
l'intérieur les bons sondages pour la
lega aux élections européennes mais
qu'il faut un feu de tout bois avec les
hasards qui tient pas là une référence
un clin d'oeil bien sûr que non mais
pourquoi ont passé et pourquoi ça ne
serait pas parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on interprète forcément voilà oui
mais il faut pas interpréter tellement
c'est tellement évident nicolas bay non
je crois que c'est pas du tout n'aurait
pas le voir bon